mon premier tournoi que j'ai fait un bep
des twins et tony qui a fait la première
photo pour moi et c'est quelqu'un qui a
marqué depuis
j'étais tout jeune lorsque j'ai commencé
et la frime au premier photo vous
c'était sous la presse
j'étais tout jeune et c'est quelqu'un
qui m'a toujours apprécié et moi aussi
parce que de qu'on appelait pour faire
des articles toujours présent c'est
quelqu'un vraiment pouvait compter sur
lui de l'association même dans le
quartier habité tout elle aussi et c'est
quelqu'un qui a fait beaucoup de choses
et c'est lorsqu'on m'a dit ça ce matin
j'allais au travail j'ai dit il faut que
je passe que ces quelques qui je pense
que c'est tout le sport c'est quelqu'un
qui a fait avec coeur lorsqu'il faisait
des actions il faisait avec coeur et la
preuve et militant pour la traite aussi